what's with the umbrella Tom I never
listened what I told you a terrible idea
I always listen to never listen you put
wings on her yeah but I didn't teach you
to fly hi I'm per seconds I'm the senior
character artist and junior meat-beef
Wrangler on the eq two team and here at
the barn we decided to give you guys
another mount we took the meat feast
there are already some interesting wings
created by Dave Brown so I took them
down basically reduced them a little bit
just a little bit of tech work and then
mid them fit the model correctly and now
you have a meat beast with wings and
from there the puppet master Tom takes
over I'm Tom Toby senior me peace
wrangler and welcome to the e key to
ranch so last year we gave you the me
peace and it was pretty popular this
year you tried the one of it and they
fly don'tdon't da a little trouble
climbing heavy utters but we're not just
giving you the me peace we're giving you
a house full of babies enjoy the flying
meet beast and the flying meet these
babies keep your eyes on the sky in Iraq
is because I'll be looking up
alright
you want a cookie